So if you were at Portsmouth in the summer, you might, if you cast your mind back, remember us presenting some UX solutions for bulk actions.
So I'll just take a look at some of the current pains that users suffer before we move on to looking at the implementation.
So the kind of main overriding pain is that setting up your portfolio and enterprise, so that's all your sites and your scans, is quite a time consuming process.
And there's a lot of little things that contribute to this huge user pain.
So this is how you currently create sites. You create them one by one going through this page, which is OK if you've got a handful of sites.
But if you've got dozens, hundreds or even thousands, then this can become quite a laborious process.
Once you've added your sites, this is an example of what your site tree might look like.
If you had the foresight to structure it this way, it would preferably resemble the structure of the organizations that you work for.
But if not, you're going to be left with a list of sites with no belongings in terms of folders structure.
So if you do want to move a site, it's going to cost you six clicks.
And if you felt the need to move 100 sites, that's going to take you all morning and 600 clicks.
And you're going to be looking like this guy here wanting to bash someone's face in.
And if that doesn't grind your gears enough, moving sites, sorry, moving folders is currently impossible in enterprise.
And on top of that, there's completely no quick way to delete scans on bulk, as well as sites,
being able to quickly create and cancel scans, and being able to rerun a scan.
So I'll hand you over to Steve now, who's going to look through the implementation with you.
Yeah, so it's a really good mask, but it's just impossible.
So I'm Steve, I'm the front-end developer for Enterprise.
I'm just going to give you a quick run-through of where we're up to with bulk actions.
So some of the pain points that Chris has just mentioned,
we'll take a look at the implementations that we've got in place to solve some of these.
The first one being bulk import of sites.
So at the top right here, we've added a new button that you can see,
where a user can simply import a CSV file of predefined sites.
Within the model that we've got visible there, we do provide a template for this,
so that they can follow a particular format, and also link to the documentation.
So we'll choose a CSV file that we've already got prepared.
When we open that up, you get an option at this point to duck out of this, basically,
and choose something else by hitting the delete button.
Or if we continue, you'll see that it says there now that we've found 22 sites in the CSV file,
and we get the option to import.
So what we will do is we will import these to an existing folder.
We've got a folder there called Folder of Dreams, which we will import those sites to.
Now, once it's actually done the import, you can see there now that we've got 20 successful imports
out of 22, and two imports have failed.
And there's also a link there that you can download the error report for that to see which ones have failed.
So once we've continued, you can see there now that in the folder of Dreams,
we've just added 20 sites to the site tree in a matter of seconds.
So the next bulk action that we'll take a quick look at is actually moving some of these.
So I mean, obviously, with the existing tree, it's quite a laborious task to move any kind of number of sites.
With the new site tree, you can see there now that on the left-hand side, we've got a checkbox that you can select,
where as soon as you make a selection of sites, you will see at the bottom there now that there is a bulk actions bar
with some actions that you can perform on that selection.
So we will move those selected sites that we've got, and we'll move them into the folder of Nightmares instead.
And you can see there now with the progress.
And again, we've now got a folder of Nightmares with the selected sites in that folder.
Again, you probably noticed on the bulk actions bar that appeared at the bottom there that there is other actions that we can perform.
So one of those is Delete or Bulk Delete.
So if we take a selection of sites from the site tree there, hit the Delete button, you can see there now that it's really simple to mass delete sites from your site tree.
The last one that you can see in the sites tree that we've got available there is if we take a selection of sites again,
there is an option there at the bottom now to quick scan these sites.
So this basically just triggers a simple scan, a single scan with the default options for that site.
So once we click that, you can see there now we hit the scan button and we get an option to be taken through to the scans page.
So on the scans page there now you can see that we've got the three sites that we just selected that are all waiting for an agent to perform a simple quick scan.
Okay, so the scans grid itself has also been given the bulk actions treatment.
So we've got checkboxes now available for multiple selection of scans that are either in progress or completed.
So there is options that we've got available so that we can select multiple scans and perform an action on those scans.
So we'll cancel the two that have just kicked off there.
Simple as that.
And further actions, of course, we've got the ability to delete multiple scans and also the ability to scan sites again.
And again, once we select those sites, click the scan again.
And that automatically sets those sites off on the scans.